it's time for the long gene kana scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Chronos code
Edward P Morgan and Larry looser both of
the CBS television news staff our
distinguished guests for this evening is
madame pendent president of the United
Nations General Assembly Madame Pandit
we remember you on your many trips from
India to this country before as a most
outspoken person and personality when
you were ambassador and in your other
capacities and we hope that nothing has
happened to you as a woman or as a
person to inhibit what you have to say
but you have been recently elevated to
the presidency of the United Nations and
were not quite sure what the
restrictions are whether it's a sort of
relation of judge to jury and you can't
talk during the case can you make some
comments for instance on India's
relations with the United States you
alright mr. Morgan and imagining that
there are some inhibitions my rule is a
little different to that of ambassador
because now as head of the United
Nations I am more or less a citizen of
the world someone who has to stay aloof
and help in the impartial in an
impartial way the proceedings of the
General Assembly therefore it would not
be possible for me to comment on any
specific issue of the type you mentioned
well let's take it from another tack in
this country and I suppose in yours when
a person gets an office he usually runs
for it it was that the case
in in your instance with the presidency
of the assembly well actually in the
case of the presidency no one runs
because you know the procedure followed
is something like that of the house of
parliament in houses of parliament House
of Commons in England there are no
nominations and there is no campaign in
my case it was a little more strange
because of course I didn't run as an
individual and when it was decided by my
government that perhaps the majority of
nations would be willing to have India
in this position I was just told to pack
up my bags and come here and I did that
independent you're the representative of
a great Asiatic country or the sister of
the Prime Minister now you're they
present with the United Nations assembly
do you feel that there is any
possibility in your position now that
you can do something about bringing
together the conflicting forces in the
world didn't you say something to that
effect at a news conference there's just
the other day couldn't we amplify that a
little yes it's true I did mention
something at my first press conference I
don't know that I can do anything
special but I do believe that the
president of the General Assembly does
have the opportunity to help towards
conciliation and and
how shall I put it of listening a gulf
that might exist
well would you want to be asked or do
you actually have any plans of your own
no I don't have any plans for two
reasons one is that in a case like this
as the situation develops the plan
emerges and in any case it would have to
be other people who would ask me to
intervene it would not be the president
who would intervene in a situation with
with any sort of a suggestion or
proposal well but it would hold yourself
in readiness if you were asked to surely
intervene Charlie yes Berlin Blockade
madame pandit how does the world
situation look to you today is it more
or less tense than it was before the
Armistice in Korea I would say it's much
less tense today in fact a few days ago
one had almost a feeling that the
tension might die out
unfortunately that hope has not been
fulfilled but even so the tension today
is very much less than it has been
during the past two or three years are
you think you have any specific
developments that caused it to turn a
little for the worse in the past few
days well I'm merely thinking in terms
of of the Korean political conference
which is not yet functioning Madame
panda may I ask you about the pointed
question do you think that your
presidency as a representative of India
will have any impact should the question
of Korea be discussed at the United
Nations I don't quite follow our two
memes to a server tie I shouldn't
imagine that would affect the situation
in any way because as I said I'm only
incidentally an Indian as assembly
president your nationality and your
country makes no difference then I take
it no you well do you think well let me
put it this way there's been a great
deal of speculation
the most of it on the negative
pessimistic side that the whole Korean
question would have to be thrown back
into the laps as it were of this
assembly well mr. Mogan the position is
this that as president of the assembly I
wouldn't like to prophesy anything we
have to wait and see how developments
take place and my job and and I believe
the job even of the responsible leaders
of delegations would be to try and and
help any development which might lead to
a fulfillment of the idea which we had
when the ceasefire in Korea was
negotiated I'm an apparent because there
are still some doubts and they were
expressed only today in that second note
that the United States sent to they ping
and and and Pyongyang do you think that
that if there will be a Korean political
conference when I'm not prepared to
comment on that but if there is none
then your position as assembly president
will have a very important role should
the whole question be thrown back to the
United Nations why do you say that my
position is president who do you mean
any president yes anything the decision
is president yes certainly the
responsibility to try and find some way
out of a situation which is delicate and
might become threatening perhaps you
would care to give apart from Korea the
three or four or more principle issues
on the agenda of this assembly madam
Pandit well of course the political
issues always seem more important to
people because of their more immediate
need for their settlement but
conservation issues that are now
before the assembly and have been for
some years are growing in importance and
I think that their solution is very very
important if we are to have any kind of
easing of that kind of tension in the
United Nations you're referring for
example is racial conflicts that exist
in the world or it has been over two
billion Africa and other places other
various things of which the United
Nations is seized at the moment then of
course there are the economic problems
problem of technical aid to which I
personally attach a great deal of
importance because I think that is one
way of proving that the United Nations
is doing a good job it's a very visible
way of showing it an apparent it I like
to ask you a question it has occurred to
me since you are the first woman
president the United Nations has ever
had and you already been in action for a
number of days now have you noticed any
signs of moderation of language of your
fellow diplomats in your present I've
been a diplomat myself and although this
is the first time I've had such an
exalted position but I've been working
with men in various fields for a long
time I don't think anybody has taken any
special pains to modulate their language
on the other hand they haven't in any
way said anything that one could take
objection to it just be the normal thing
I know you'd have to wrap your gavel a
very vigorously a few times Oh madam
patted many people not only Americans
but others seem to to have become over
the years pessimistic tanned discouraged
about the United Nations as an
instrument of peace do you think that is
justified no there are moments I suppose
in the life of everyone when certain
situations look gloomy and one feels
unhappy
about them but I have great faith in the
United Nations and I do believe that it
has done a great deal towards keeping
peace in the world after all if we look
back and see the record of the United
Nations for some of its failures there
are also things like Palestine whether
fighting was stopped Korea where we have
just achieved an armistice and so on
what does the average Indian think of
the United Nations well you know India
is a long way from the United Nations
from New York and I supposed to be quite
honest adults was the average Indian has
much thought about it I can tell you
what my constituents think some of them
they write and ask me why I'm not
attending to my duties in Parliament
instead of sitting here trying to bring
peace to the world that doesn't want not
very different from an American reaction
very I don't I think people are pretty
much the same all over but by and large
there is an increasing understanding of
the fact that the UN is doing a big job
in maintaining the status quo even if
it's doing nothing else
as an Indian that Asia is emerging as a
third force between these two
conflicting ideologies in the world well
I don't know about I wouldn't put it
that way I'd say certainly Asia is
emerging as a third force a third force
in the interests of peace I don't know
that she's so keen to emerge as a force
between any two ideologies thank you
very much Madame Pandit the opinions
that you've heard our speakers expressed
tonight have been entirely their own the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Crona scope was Edward P
Morgan and Larry looser our
distinguished guest was madam pendant
president of the United Nations General
Assembly